first question here in the front room
kawaii congratulations for tonight
Valero be Nova sport a lot of injuries
on both sides after playing so many
games how do you manage to maximize your
performance while playing through pain
do you need to do something specific
before as a warm up or after the game to
feel better oh yeah for sure you know
you do your warmup good treatment before
the game off days days after the game
whatever that could help you speed your
recovery up so you up with a play the
next day next question here in the
second row and the
hey cool him obviously you guys are
effective offensively but your defense
is really what obviously shine tonight
oh four Pistons come to mind 2014 before
Pistons come to mind 2014 Spurs also
come to mind you were obviously with
Danny on that team can you just describe
the differences between the team in 2014
that you were on with Danny and this one
defensively
I mean we're playing two different teams
I think we're a lot younger we could
switch pretty much surgeries in the
lineup one through five and I don't know
I mean it's hard to say I got to watch a
film and see what see what I see but
from for the most part that's a pretty
much stick style but probably a little
bit longer a little bit more athletic
and you know able to switch like one
through five wobble it's a VSO Kawhi
could you talk a little bit about that
first quarter on your teammates were
struggling a little bit with their shot
you were more aggressive in that first
quarter trying to keep you guys in the
game is there something as kind of
leader of the team you got a feel in
that you didn't want it to get away from
you on the road and that's how you
decided to come out and attack that yeah
and at the same time I knew you know I
had faith that we it was gonna turn
around for us we was missing a lot of
wide-open shots you know you know
obviously I was getting to my spots and
shooting the ball but um like you said
as the quarter went on towards the last
four or five minutes you know I try to
stay as aggressive as possible get to my
spots be confident shoot the basketball
you know you know what the net for a
first quarter still was passing the ball
you know when a my team is still staying
at rhythm um and know that I'm gonna
give him the ball when they're hoping
kawaii pateen a lot of gazeta Italy you
win three games out of four against the
team always mention
we talk about best dynasty ever what
makes you better than them so far I mean
it's not over yet so I can't say that
we're better you know just the key to
tonight's win was pretty much as you
guys know playing defense and you know
you know towards that second half we
started to make some shots for the game
stating in game constantly in your team
that has made the difference three times
out of four like I don't know your
determination your ability to defend or
you pretty much just set it on you know
our defense and you know it's you know
willing to stay in the game have faith
not put our head down knowing that we're
gonna make shots and you know that's
pretty much what happened tonight for
throw towards the center role in The
Guardian Kauai you obviously had an
explosive third quarter and so did your
team I'm just curious what was said
during halftime nothing really um we're
confident you know Ron come in and have
a good third quarter film come out the
first five mates um stay aggressive on
both ends of the floor keep our energy
up that's all we did a rash over the
back right quite you're right a rash
modeun from sports night further to that
this isn't a team that gets outscored by
60 this isn't a team that gets outscored
by 16 especially either break they're a
good third quarter team how do you think
you guys are able to keep your foot on
the gas pedal throughout till then
obviously just stay focused on um you
know cleaning staff you know just trying
to make sure they don't get in you know
just trying to make sure they don't get
in too good of a rhythm you know they're
great players just try to make sure we
could test them as much as possible and
then on the other end just come down and
you know try to have some ball movement
some flow some paste and you know just
make hard cuts and just believe stay
confident in your shot
I do notice we have Michael over here in
left side
why Michael Grange from Sports Net know
we're down this no I mean you're staying
in the moments kind of in your theme all
season but you are one game away from an
NBA title does that sort of make it a
little more difficult to stay in the
moment and how do you feel about that
going into Game five you just got to be
patient wait you know who games away
four games away
it doesn't matter till you get that
fourth win yeah you know we just have to
stay confident in ourselves be patient
they confident in ourselves be patient
don't try to rush things and see how it
plays out next question back right here
you guys had some more problems when
they switched up straight up and instead
of when they went double-team you guys
whether it was you or Kyle
were you surprised they were not
switching more especially in that fourth
quarter just try and W up like that pass
you'll have four Danny when Steph helped
off the strong side corner you're saying
was I surprised they didn't switch more
and not double no I thought we play well
they put the bags on her guards and we
attacked and you know may passes in we
made shots or drove and found somebody
under the rim and the end of the room
and no not really I didn't think of it
like that
we just kept playing a game and read and
react was posted so you guys were able
to stay level-headed opposed to what
this season yeah how were you able to do
that and I'm how did it affect the shape
of the team how did it affect the shape
of the team I mean just like just going
through the season you know having our
ups and downs our experiences as a team
of you know having bad streaks of losing
or winning just you know within our
huddle take those experiences and
you know keep moving and learn from them
and just all talk to each other really
and just keep our mind set on one go
mine said on one go last question on the
right side Kauai Jonathan Jody a TV if
the Raptors win the NBA title what do
you think this will mean for Canada and
the Toronto Raptors you've already won
with the San Antonio Spurs you've seen
the way it impacted that community what
do you think this will do for Canada
sure I guess you really have to ask
somebody on the street or one of our
fans I'm pretty sure just a long time
waiting they're gonna pretty sure just a
long time waiting they're gonna be
excited man they are they're already
excited just says just being here for
the first time a decent Conference
Finals and I don't know there's no
telling you got a eggs probably like
like I said a fan or somebody I said a
fan or somebody I think and I've been
living in Canada for a while but I mean
I know they're gonna be super excited I
don't know we'll see
thank you quite this concludes the
session here for tonight